[Music]
lunch is a good look - did you have a
rough day agent fury I'm gonna need
clarification on this space invasion
Scrolls are infiltrating your planet
they're shapeshifters
[Music]
okay prove you're not scroll that's a
photon blast and house croaking I'll do
that I'm just supposed to take your word
today
[Music]
we are Cree strong United
remember control
I have this power
but I don't know where it came from I've
never seen anything like her you think
you can find us
she's just the beginning
[Music]
you come a long way leaner strong as you
think
what is this shoe logo does announcing
your identity on clothing help with the
covert part of your job said the space
soldier was wearing a rubber suit
get tickets now
[Music]
translating for a tunnel up ahead
let's treat them at the station
tell me about this dream anything here
no it's closing you down how it makes
you vulnerable
control them rush your head up in the
clouds where's yours
I'm not shoulders about to show these
boys how we do it you ready higher
further faster baby that's right
[Music]
oh you want to get personal
where are you born Huntsville Alabama
but technically I don't remember that
part name your first minute mr. snow mr.
snoopers that's what I said not pass not
yet first job soldier straight out of
high school got the rights a full-bird
colonel then spy where there's a cold
war room everywhere belfast
Bucharest Belgrade Budapest I like to be
a second make him right now then riding
a desk for the past six years trying to
figure out where future enemies are
coming from
never occurred to me they would be
coming from above Naima details so
bizarre a scroll could never fabricate
it toasters cut diagonally I can't eat
it you didn't need that did you no no I
didn't but I enjoyed it okay your turn
Ruby another scroll so scrolls are the
bad guys and you're a free a race of
noble warriors heroes noble warrior he
rubs
when we meet Carol in this film the Cree
part of her is your identity we see the
cream on one side of a war that they've
been engaged in for generations and
there's force of creased soldiers that
Carol is a part up called the Star Force
there are really incredible warriors the
best at what they do everything they do
is for the good of the cream is a real
kind of pride in that
I see Star Force fighting a war against
a shape-shifting enemy called us girls
the Kree see the scrolls as their
greatest threat they've got like a
chameleon ability but you know amped up
Carol knows the skulls have infiltrated
earth and it kind of craves the sense of
paranoia prove you're not a Skrull I was
creeping I'll do that this girls are
asked or something and part of the
mystery of the movie is Carol trying to
figure out what they're after
and getting it before they do this war
is just a beginning
so scrolls are the bad guys
and you're a Cree a race of noble
warriors heroes noble warrior heroes
[Music]
your life began the day it nearly ended
we found you with no memory we made you
one of us so you could live longer
stronger superior
you were reborn
I keep having these
memories something in my past is the key
to all of this
you know how to fly this thing you'll
see that's a yes or no question yes
[Music]
would you like to know
what you really are
I think there had a life here
what aren't you telling me
we've come a long way
but you know as strong as you think
[Music]
the small cysts the beginning I'm not
gonna fight your war
[Music]
I'm gonna end it
[Music]
[Music]
I'm sure the cutest thing aren't you
what's your name
effortless enigmatic fearless talented
refined iconic
no thanks Bree oh I was actually just
talking about this oh yeah
well yes Ozai
[Music]
we need heroes we need Captain Marvel is
about somebody who goes on a journey of
discovery and I think it was really
important for Bri to learn how to fight
by the time we started shooting I had
been training for nine months
and I'm glad that I did doing my
sequences up and down or training for
three days well kind of alive
the thing that I found so unique about
this character was that sense of humor
mixed with total capability and whatever
challenge comes her way you know how to
fly this thing you see which I realized
after going to Air Force Base is really
what Air Force pilots are like that's a
yes-or-no question
yes
we simulated a dogfight we were on
offense we were on the defense we got to
6.5 G's is amazing it's a lot a lot of
work she brings so much of that to the
role it's pretty awesome
dr. Sophy sois how do you do it you
ready higher further faster baby yes
[Music]
faster
try to keep up
[Music]
war is a universal language
I know renegade so to horsie never
occurred to me that one might come from
above
space invasion
big car chase
truth be told I was ready to hang it up
to let miss you today so you're not from
around here it's hard to explain
I keep having these memories
I see flashes
[Music]
I think I had a life here
[Music]
but I can't tell if it's real
we have no idea what threats are out
there
we can't do this alone
we need you
I'm not what you think I am
we need heroes
[Music]
[Music]
I'm ready
captain marvel get tickets now
[Music]